H
TO CONSUMERS.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS CHARLIE
GASPARINO FROM FOXBUSINESS.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
I WILL REPEAT JEFF BEZOS
QUESTION.
I WAS READING A LITTLE BIT.
IS THIS PURPOSEFUL MISDIRECTION
OR JUST A COMPLETE FINANCIAL
ILLITERACY OF BASIC MARKET
DYNAMICS?
>> WELL, IT'S ALWAYS INVOLVED,
BUT THIS IS A PARTICULARLY
ECONOMICALLY, I WANT TO SAY
ILLITERATE BUT A PRESIDENT THAT
LACKS LITERACY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE ECONOMY.
IT'S NOT JUST ON THIS ONE.
THIS IS OBVIOUS.
MOST OF THE GAS STATION OWNERS
ARE SMALL BUSINESS PEOPLE THAT
OPERATE ON THIN MARGINS.
THE MINUTE THAT THE PRICE ON THE
FUTURES MARKETS GO DOWN IT IS
NOT REFLECTED IN WHAT THEY HAVE
ALREADY PAID FOR THE STUFF THAT
YOU ARE PUMPING IN THE TANKS.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO RIP
PEOPLE OFF.
MOM & POP ARE NOT TRYING TO RIP
THE OTHER BASIC STUFF IS ABOUT
RAISING TAXES ON BILLIONAIRES SO
WE CAN LOWER INFLATION.
THAT AIN'T GOING TO HAPPEN
EITHER.
YOU RAISE TAXES ON UPPER INCOME
PEOPLE AND THE SMALL BUSINESSES
ACTUALLY WILL PASS DOWN THAT
COST TO CONSUMERS SO IT MAY
INCREASE INFLATION.
WE COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT
THIS.
IT'S A SCARY TIME IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
WHEN I HEAR FROM MY CEO SOURCES
WHO ARE MODERATES, WHO ARE
DEMOCRATS, WHO GO NUTS EVERY
TIME TRUMP PUT OUT A TWEET ABOUT
SOMETHING IN THE WORLD IS COMING
TO AN END.
THEY ARE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
JOE BIDEN AND THAT HE DOES NOT
HAVE THE ECONOMIC CHOPS, THE
INTELLECTUAL CHOPS I SHOULD SAY,
TO DEAL WITH WHAT COULD BE
COMING AT US.
WE COULD HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
WE HAVE INFLATION.
IT MAY BE COMING DOWN BUT IT'S
COMING DOWN BECAUSE THE ECONOMY
IS STARTING TO SLOW AND IT MAY
SLOW DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY.
IF YOU HAVE SOMEONE THAT IS THIS
ECONOMICALLY PICK YOUR
ADJECTIVE, HOW WILL WE DO THIS?
ONE OF THE PROBLEM IS NOT THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT UP TO PAR
HERE WHEN IT COMES TO DEALING
WITH THE ECONOMY.
HE SURROUNDED HIMSELF LITERALLY
WITH IDEOLOGUES ON THE LEFT.
YOU CAN GO UP AND DOWN THE LINE.
THANK OF THE MOST ECONOMICALLY
ASTUTE PERSON IN THE WHITE HOUSE
RIGHT NOW IS PROBABLY BRIAN
DIETZ.
HE'S THE HEAD OF THE NATIONAL
ECONOMIC COUNCIL.
BEFORE HE WENT TO WASHINGTON HE
SPENT A COUPLE YEARS AT BLACK
ROCK, THE BIG MONEY MANAGEMENT
FIRM.
HE WASN'T THERE MANAGING MONEY
AND HANDLING PORTFOLIOS AND
TRADING STOCKS.
THAT WOULD GIVE HIM RELEVANT
EXPERIENCE FOR THE ECONOMY.
HE WAS THEIR PUSHING THE COMPANY
TO ADOPT ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL
STANDARDS.
NOT TO MAKE MONEY AND FIGURE OUT
MARKETS.
HE WAS ESSENTIALLY A GREEN
ADVOCATE WITHIN BLACKROCK.
HE WAS PROPHET TITHING ABOUT
THIS ESG STUFF.
HE'S PROBABLY THE BEST GUY THEY
GOT.
JANET YELLEN MISSED EVERYTHING
WHEN IT CAME TO INFLATION AND
THE ECONOMY.
SHE PRINTED MONEY LIKE CRAZY.
>> CHARLIE, YOU ARE BEING
CHARITABLE OR DIPLOMATIC OR
BOTH.
AT SOME POINT, I AM GETTING THAT
FROM YOU A LITTLE BIT.
AT SOME POINT, WHEN DOES THIS
BECOME PURPOSEFUL SABOTAGE?
IT IS NOT THAT COMPLICATED, HOW
TO GET US BACK TO ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE IF YOU WANT.
THEY DON'T WANT THAT.
THAT IS CLEAR.
>> IT'S AN IDEOLOGICAL ROUTE.
THE LEFT CONTROLS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ON ALL SORTS OF
POLICIES.
THE HEAD OF THE NEC IS A LEFTY
THAT PROFIT TIES ABOUT ESG GOALS
WHICH HAS LED TO OIL COMPANIES
CUTTING BACK ON PRODUCTION.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS.
YOU CAN GO UP AND DOWN THE LINE.
IT'S A SCARY SITUATION.
WE HAVE INFLATION.
THE FED HAS TO TIGHTEN STUFF.
IT HAS TO TIGHTEN THE MONEY
SUPPLY AND BRING DOWN DEMAND ON
TOP OF A BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
THAT IS PURPOSEFULLY KEEPING
SUPPLY LOW.
YOU HAVE THE WORST OF BOTH
WORLDS.
THAT'S WHY YOU HERE'S THE HEAD
OF JPMORGAN CHASE SAYING A STORM
IS COMING OR A HURRICANE.
>> JAMIE IS ALL IN IN CHINA